[Music]
to rajer Ramis a stun performer whose
film credits include black panther
Avengers endgame and The Suicide Squad
died on October 31st in a vehicle
collision in Georgia he was 41 years old
his four children were also in the
vehicle with him two of whom also died
at the scene while his 10-year-old son
was placed on life support but died
shortly thereafter the crash happened
shortly before midnight on Halloween
night they say that he was on his way
home when his truck and an 18wheeler
collided ramses's mother confirmed the
news on Instagram writing all who knew
and met him know how special to Raja was
he had a deep capacity for love and
loved his children more than all he
loved his martial arts motorcycles and
all things related to film making he had
a very draw yet wicked sense of humor
and yet could be as cornball corny as
can be director Ava duvan released her
own statement to Instagram rames was a
crew member member for the Selma
filmmakers Distribution Company aray
duven wrote Taja Regal that's the word
that comes to mind when I think of him
he walked like a king and to me always
acted like one he loved making movies
and TV too held many positions over the
years immersing himself in all aspects
of The Craft Ramis is passing as a
devastating loss to the stun Community
with him having helped bring to life
numerous moments from some of the most
popular films of the last several years
rames brought his passion for martial
arts into a variety of stunt work for
numerous high-profile projects his first
stunt credit came in 2015 when he served
as a stunt double for Papa midnight in
an episode of Constantine from there he
appeared in a string of comic book
adaptations doing stuns for Black
Lightning She-Hulk attorney at law and
Black Adam he even has some on camera
appearances as he appears as a wakandan
soldier in Avengers Infinity War the
groomsman in what men want rames also
had experience in the art department for
various Productions he's worked as an
onset dresser who is responsible for
arranging objects on a set before the
cameras roll on many film and TV sets
including the Hunger Games Catching Fire
Furious 7 and what men want looking over
his resume it becomes abundantly clear
that Ramses was a singular Talent who
excelled in many different disciplines
he was a key behind the scenes figure he
will be missed by all those who worked
with him them numerous professionals
have populated his mother's Instagram
tribute with kind words of their own to
remember how dedicated Ramses was to his
craft fashion designer tamama Foster
empathized with her situation posting as
a mom who has lost a son my heart breaks
for you I'm truly sorry for your loss I
will pray for your grandbabies as well
AA Carrie bernon shared her own special
connection with Ramses posting my
deepest condolences he was truly an
incredible person to work with we worked
on the setled Black Panther together and
he's always been such a joy to be around
and full of life and love sending you
all much prayers and love Ramses is
passing is a huge loss both for the
entertainment community and his
immediate family after his death a
GoFundMe was established for his mother
to help cover any forthcoming expenses
and has already received more than
$87,000 in donations as of the making of
this
video